this great big story was made possible
by Wells Fargo established 1852
reestablished 2018
[Music]
when you talk about metal are talking
about you you are talking about how you
feel Adi good what you will die for it's
all about freedom freedom expression
what you do energy like metal is just
being yourself as simple
[Music]
okay so Mad Max or Comicon in the desert
nope this is winter metal mania festive
just a bunch of metalheads that want to
prove that Botswana can trash as good as
the rest
Hey and none go harder than these guys
[Music]
Oh solonius budget rusts I'm over trusts
death metal band frontman bassist and
lead vocalist what was this a family
been displayed because his family such a
way that we have been brothers pleased
together
heavy metal build us up tuna the die
hard death metal band formed back in
2008 and have worked their way to become
one of the country's leading acts
when I get on stage it's just like hell
the moment I get there I realized I'm
not my normal thing that I am matter
that thing gets into me like an
electrons of the electricity it gives me
that power and when I growl out I
realized that this is what is supposed
to be happening
[Music]
but SWANA might not be the first country
that comes to mind for this for this but
the metal scene here has some momentum
it's not surprising but saunas here is
the heavy metal community we have
priests past past office that metalheads
they see nothing wrong with that they
come for our shows for nine years over
trust has been headlining their festival
part of a lineup that now hosts acts
from all over Africa we have embedded a
bent from Angola the Fantasma they play
trash we have a bent from Mozambique
they play technical data
nevermind then we have ten local bands
that were the journalist it's a global
metal family they are so so special and
so different from any other generous
[Applause]
and for vulture thrust like any true
metalhead it's about so much more than
the music
[Music]
the insalata just build me up internet
in the person I am you see with
metalhead is about how you feel how you
with is free summer freedom respect
loyalty and type what you believe I'm a
metalhead for life
[Music]
you
[Music]